من بيروت ينضم الينا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه العميد الياس حنا اهلا بك
عميد الياس ونريد ان نشخص الوضع في باخمه
تحديدا بالامس كان هناك حديث عن امكانيه
التطوير قريبا اليوم هناك حديث عن ان هذه
القوات تمكنت بالفعل من تطبيق المدينه
والدخول الى بعض البلدات فيها ما مدى
خطوره الوضع في ضخمه
مياده يجب ان نفهم بخموت من ضمن الصوره
الاكبر يعني هناك ثلاث محاور اساسيه للجيش
الروسي نبدا من الشمال الشرقي
كريمينا وحتى كوبيانسك وهذه المنطقه هي
منطقه صدام وليست منطقه هجوم وهجوم عكسي
في الوسط مخموت هي المنطقه الوحيده التي
يستطيع الجيش الروسي بعد ثمانيه اشهر ان
يحقق تقدما معين عبر التطويق والذهاب الى
ما يسمى بالانجليزيه الكولدرن او المرجل
يعني التطبيق من كافه الجبهات من كافه
الجهات وضع المدفعيه وبالتالي تدمير هذه
المنطقه وهي اصبحت مدمره اما من جهه
الجنوب فياتي اوغليدار مريض مارينكا
هذه ايضا جبهه تقريبا ثابته حتى الان
المكان الاساسي هو بخموت هل ستنسحب القوات
الاوكرانيه الان غدا والى اين وكيف تخدم
الصمود او الهجوم المرحله القادمه ان كان
للاستراتيجيه الروسيه او ان كان
الاستراتيجيه الاوكرانيه في مرحله الاعداد
الهجوم القادم هناك كانت انباء ايضا عن
وجود دبابات لبرد بالقرب من باخموت هل
يمكن لذلك ان يكون مؤشرا عسكريا
بالطبع هناك دبابات ليوبار الجديده التي
اتت الى الشاذيفيار وهي تقريبا غرب مدينه
مخموض وقد تكون هذا دليل مؤشر تكتيكي على
الارض قد يعطينا صوره او لمحه عن المرحله
القادمه وكانه شذب في ار قد تكون مرحله او
خد دفاع ثاني اخر وراء مدينه او في غرب
مدينه مخمود ايضا الهدف دائما مياده هو
تاخير التقدم الروسي نزال العديد الكثير
من الخسائر استعدادا لاستكمال التجهيزات
الاوكرانيه لمرحله الهجوم الموعود او الذي
يحضر له لاحقا وبالتزامن مع كل ذلك تستمر
الضربات عبر المسيرات سواء من الجانب
الروسي في العمق الاوكراني او في محاولات
من الجانب الاوكراني باتجاه روسيا هذا
الاستخدام دائما يتزامن ايضا مع احتدام
المعارك في جبهات معينه كبخمت كيف يمكن
ايضا قراءه ذلك
اليوم عندنا نتحدث عن المسيرات التي بدات
بسبتمبر كان العدد كبير جدا اليوم العدد
اقل لماذا منهم من يقول ان استنفذ المخزون
من المسيرات الايرانيه شاهد 136 ومنهم من
يقول ان الصين ستحل محل الشاهد 136 وتزود
روسيا بالمسيرات وهذا هنا ياتي
التحذير الامريكي ولكن دائما هذه المسيرات
هي وانتحاريه تستعمل بدل المدفعيه انها
ازكى من المدفعيه تحمل تقريبا قذيفتين من
دبابه عيار او مدفعيه يار 155 ولكن هذا من
ضمن النمط اللي اعتدنا عليه ضرب العمق ضرب
امكانيه الصمود الاوكراني للمرحله القادمه
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من بيروت الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العميدي ليسحب